I learned very quickly that there's not
a shot I'm ever going to be a special
forces operator oh why I did a a USO
tour in um 2006 out of that when did
comedy with dub David off Steve Burns
Sam Tripoli what was your dad like
blowing up weddings and [ __ ] like that
or like
hey bro
by the way to keep you safe
if you did learn something from a from a
kind of a special forces guy where they
would when they would kill an Isis guy
yeah they would put a tracking device in
the guy's body and then they when they
had the funeral oh kill the funeral dude
all and all the guys all your comrades
come and they [ __ ] look at it like an
airplane
but just to understand how do they pick
the wedding because we've had some
conversations about this like are they
talking to the Isis or Al-Qaeda people
and like well so the weddings were
always but there were a couple I hate my
in-laws just do this one
that's exactly what it is oh really I
got it right you got it right holy [ __ ]
dude let me see your papers say again no
it's not it's not like that no so so
your father was Tom Clancy my dad my dad
look I grew up all over the world all
right I was born in the Philippines I
lived in India wait a minute Bombay hold
on hold on you were born in Philippines
I was born in the Philippines you've
I've had eyebrow surgery or whatever
I've had
yes nothing else has been tightened this
is awesome that's natural except for
this area and um this guy's the most
Asian [ __ ] dude on the planet yeah
dog holy [ __ ] Brian Karen dude
that's all I'm gonna say if I were to
strike you you're born in the
Philippines born in the Philippines then
we moved to India Bombay and Calcutta
two places in India
yo [ __ ] you don't say that's two two
different places otherwise known as
Mumbai yeah okay okay yeah then we go
well your dad always say about the uh
the time in India I put the bomb in
Bombay
this is my long-lost brother
he had he sires you um and then uh
I love it I like using Old English
but I gotta say it's it's good to be
hither yeah and um and then
and then and then and then we went to
then we moved to Beirut whoa to Lebanon
then Pakistan
yeah oh damn you got one yes Karachi
Pakistan in the house bro come on great
memories what wait wait why do they have
great memories
no problem stop reading my mind okay I
mean sorry sorry sorry and then our
Pakistani women good lovers look I was a
young kid man how do I know that's not
what I asked you yeah it's a good point
he didn't ask you you're very demure
Pakistan's a very conservative culture
yeah but when you get them in the sheets
languages
uh I I speak French well that's not any
of the languages well but Lebanon Beirut
yeah Lebanon was French and Paris to the
Middle East and I used to speak Arabic
it is the Paris that how about that
he'll surprise you it's a Paris in the
Middle East thank you yeah thank you so
many reads over here I do Lebanon again
you know who doesn't read the women in
Lebanon
come on we tried to change the regime
okay no we did not in Lebanon well I
mean that's a longer if you want to get
into geopolitics we'll do that for this
yeah I want to get into it what is your
dad's issue with ports there well I I'm
not I'm not a liberty to say again again
he didn't have anything to do with that
bomb God damn it I'm just saying then we
moved back to Lebanon after Pakistan
yeah and the war broke out I got stuck
in the war for six months living in the
Holiday Inn and in the basement of the
Holiday Inn
I was I was 11
10 and 11. wow we get evacuated to
Greece you're like Anne Frank I know
you're thinking that same evacuated and
then Saudi Arabia so I came to the
United States when I was 14. and look at
how good my [ __ ] English is and I'm
so well adjusted I know yeah your Xbox
moved every two years yeah 100 people to
be fair you don't speak any languages
except French in English
his accent is fantastic can you come on
Morocco you know that Mark also speaks
yeah but he speaks
oh that's terrible that sounds so bad it
sounds like you ran out of batteries
he's not he's not from Morocco no no no
no no no no no no
wow okay so you come to America at 14.
you're impressed you're quietly
impressed yeah
yeah okay so you come here chicken in my
body and yeah
you go to boarding school why because my
parents were still in Saudi Arabia and
it started your parents went to Saudi
Arabia yeah I'm sorry how'd your family
leave a Trail of Tears around the Middle
East and Asia well some people would say
my dad was a banker and other people
would say my dad did other [ __ ] oh wow I
said what bank my dad was my dad was
like the one over there oh wow can you
can you at least clear up the room is is
your father Henry Kissinger that's that
that was that's what some people said
the funny people do stuff I've met Henry
Kissinger through my dad because he he
uh had sex with your mom and made you oh
my God
why you don't give me some some
attention I don't know why I'm speaking
with that accent Papa give me attention
okay that sounds Brazilian anyway yes no
I met Henry Kissinger and I wasn't
father moderated a debate between him
and Brzezinski and all those people whoa
yeah that's how old I am
still alive he's 100 years
he looks like a mollusk yeah
melted into himself okay incredible
um wow dude so your father was really
like involved in like shaving World
policy and so were you in a lot I don't
really well I don't know I mean it's I
mean you were deeply involved in all
these decisions I would imagine I I mean
he would consult me a lot of you like
Dad if you were so high up why were we
in a [ __ ] Holiday Inn facts but that
might yeah but that's that's that's
called your cover ah oh can't be too off
if you're in the bougie spot they're
gonna know it's you yeah I mean so I'm
so I look like this now now you want to
get busy in a dark alley and I'm going
to look at you I'm not gonna Flex my
muscles I'm just gonna look at you and
go you want to dance and then all of a
sudden now you're on your back what is
your chosen martial art in a uh to be
completely honest yeah it's just it's
just death touch has that it's it's here
and my chi goes into your heart
but here's a good thing yeah I divide
you afterwards and I go we okay
uh because you're not a killer no you're
trying to you're trying to be the chain
so you want to kill you I change your
mind okay give you a second chance yeah
I break your spirit yeah and then I go
and I and I leave my card in your pocket
and I go if you want to learn how to do
this stuff yeah I'll be at the Holiday
Inn the holiday is your birthday welcome
to make a wish I can't believe all my
secrets are being exposed no they're not
being exposed yeah this is a tight-knit
circle and everybody here is in the
dresser and nobody nobody watches this
yeah nobody's gonna watch this now Alex
believes that he's uh he could beat up
every single white guy do you consider
yourself White
I'm I'm half Sicilian
okay black black right whoa whoa at
least at least Turkish at least Arabic
because when I went back and traced my
lineage in Sicily yeah Arabic writing on
the [ __ ] on where my family came from
on the wall
Sicilians just got ran through by
everybody
they would just let whoever wanted to
come in just rinse out all their women
and that's why that's what their
cultural Mark is on the world it's like
oh do you want to come rinse out our
women for a few hundred years yeah it's
my great grandmother
[Laughter]
I mean it kind of it's the most
conquered city in the world and my
family you know Italians tend to be did
they ever try to fight back
why what was that because they were
Merchants because the clothes it's our
thing because it was really everyone's
things you can fight back or you can
just assimilate and be like you [ __ ]
go date his brother he's got money oh
just we're trading look at my hands I'm
not they're not made to hold a sword
they're made to serve what is the thumb
about dude you have a weird thumb like
that well that now that yeah what is
that about that right there this is a
true story Yeah I broke it punching
somebody what was her name
she identifies as a man now and that's
the importance okay you got lucky with
that yes he was a Eurasian man whoa and
a tall man and I I struck him I hooked
him like why and broke my uh what
happened to get to get you to fight what
did it take it was in it was in my
martial arts studio and we were sparring
when I was in college ah
so so again if you want to [ __ ] with me
I'll keep you busy